and uh
okay so
in this talk actually we'll be
revisiting issues about
uh regret
uh
price of anarchy
and different class of equilibria
like nasa equilibria correlate
equilibria courseworld equilibria
but once again
we'll be doing this from our own
uh
noble perspective of dynamical systems
okay
and uh we'll be gaining some like new
and i would say uh
somewhat surprising insights about what
these concepts uh mean and imply okay
so this part of the talk actually would
be actually half and half
so
the first half of the talk would be
almost like you know classical knowledge
that uh in the
price of finality
robustness framework and so forth and
even
like you know just seeing that the
formal definitions of different
equilibrium concepts
so hopefully you know for most of so
forth for most of you maybe this is uh
it's well known but like maybe for some
of the newcomers of some of the
participants from the other workshop
this would be useful
okay but the second part of the talk is
actually going to be brand new
so it's going to be
results that come by putting this this
classical framework
together with again the dynamical system
perspective so what happens is you take
price of anarchy
uh course called equilibria correlate
equilibria
you know
yeah
and you put them together with chaos
like how do these things even make sense
together okay
and i think we'll see that
there's some other counterintuitive
things emerging
all right so let's go to the easy part
so you know
uh to see basically you can sleep now
and then i'll i'll let you in when when
the new stuff all right
okay all right so here's the definition
of congestion games
all right so
[Music]
all right so this is the
okay this is arguably one of the most
well-known clash of games uh arguably
maybe the most well-known outside the
zero sum games
so these are games are you can think of
this as roughly trying to model traffic
routing okay so this is the atomic case
so you have like a discrete number of
agents and
and you have a number of resources or
edges and it's a strategy corresponds to
a
set of resources um typically
although not necessarily a path in some
sort like network
and each edge has a cost
that determines its cost as a function
of the number of people that are using
it so think of the the delay of going
through that edge
that is statistically increasing as more
agents pylon
on it and the cost experienced by a
player is just the sum of the edge costs
okay so here's an example
so i have a red player
and a green player
the red player has these two strategies
available like this path and this path
he wants to go from this source this
destination node
similarly the green agent wants to go
from this to this destination node
and let's say here's the strategy
profile
so the cost for the red agent is one
along the first edge then plus two plus
two plus one equals to six
and the cost for the green agent is like
two
plus two plus two plus two equals eight
okay so that's a configuration
and then
a motivating example that that's useful
to keep in mind is the simplest possible
in some sense special case where you
have let's say
n players and n parallel links each of
them have a cost equal to x okay
so
all right so these games are also known
as
balls and beans games
because you can think the players as
being balls and then you choose your
bean and your cost is the number of
other balls which are like in the same
bin again right
so
and okay there's a there's a reason why
potential games are like you know
hold such a special place in game theory
uh consistent game sorry and now the
reason is that they
they're effectively uh isomorphic with
another very important class of games
which are known as potential games
so potential games are games that have a
that come up with a single function phi
so that's that when you have exactly one
agent deviating
from any given configuration so
everybody else stays as is
and i deviate from some strategy to
another to si prime okay
then the difference in my utility
is captured exactly by the difference
between uh the potential function
between the same uh the same two
outcomes okay
and why is very important because of
course
now uh okay so what is not clear at all
but just take it and believe me for this
is it like
the congestion games that was from the
previous slide
they have a simply actually computable
such potential function right and the
opposite direction is also true it's
even more surprising
so for every such potential game if you
write me if you give me such a potential
game i can actually construct
a congestion game from the previous
slider isomorphic okay so this means
like both agents in both games you have
the same number of agents same
strategies and uh for every
configuration is uh you have the same
the same utilities
okay um all right the reason why we like
these games is because uh every
it's a local maximum local minimum
depending on if it's a it's a cost of a
utility game
it's a nasa equilibrium and that's
clearly and also like every sort of like
best response path and actually more
general learning dynamics
like they act as a yapunov on the
potential which let's say strictly
decreases
up until the system equilibrates okay so
this is the the prototype of
equilibriating
games okay
and as i said like okay here's the other
class of games of course are very
important
which are like zero-sum games because we
all know this
we all know the definition of nash okay
every player has a profitable
product of mixed strategies okay
right and then
somehow like we meet
already uh
one of the most important problems uh in
game theory this equilibrium selection
process a problem
and this is like quickly unless you're
playing a trivia like a game like zero
sum game
which has a well-defined utility for all
nas equilibria so effectively
effectively unique solution
like in these games you have two
different nas equilibria this
equilibrium can be quite distinct okay
in terms of let's say the social welfare
the sum of the utilities of the agents
and so forth
so which nas should one choose okay this
is this is actually as i said like a
deep question
and
and uh papado material back in uh now
more than 20 years ago they came up with
a fundamental idea
that's just like okay just do worst case
analysis so if many equilibria exist
just take the worst okay
and then the hope
is that like if you look at the social
cost which let's say the sum of the
agents costs
at this worst case equilibrium then uh
this this course case equilibrium won't
be
clearly its cost would be worse than the
cost of the optimum state okay but maybe
won't be too much warsaw okay and if
it's not too much worse off then maybe
we don't really care about which
equilibrium gets elected all of them are
roughly qualified
okay so that's the idea
what's muscle is clear is that like this
idea hasn't shown like legs to walk on
uh here's an example of a of a
congestion game
so you have 10 agents
and they all want to go
from point a to point d
and i claim here right so
the nas equilibrium of all of the agents
going through this zigzag path
and then they have a delay of 20
but if you were to split yourself like
50 50. so five agents above and five
rates and below you have uh a cost of uh
uh you know five and ten ten fifteen
okay so this ratio
this this price of final key for this
simple
for the simple law and that's actually
the unique equilibrium so the price of
final key for this uh for this uh as a
unique pure
the price of our key for this game is is
four over three
okay
uh okay so and this is like a relatively
simple network okay
so
uh what's really amazing is that
kutsukis and crystal lulu again
uh almost 20 years ago
like they proved that okay forget about
this very simple network create a crazy
big network like you know a billion
edges
like a million users
like put uh whatever you want but uh
linear delays okay
then the price of anarchy cannot be too
much worse than four over three actually
would be at most uh five over two okay
so that was a
fundamental idea
and then uh actually
ralph garden
uh came back
in 09
and he he developed like a way to
systematize
uh all of these uh proofs in a in a
framework that's known as the lambda
mishmos framework
what's the idea here is that
well suppose you have a game and then i
don't tell you how but suppose that you
can prove this property for this game
so
take any two configurations
as strategy profiles s and s prime
and then you want to have this
you want to have this this uh inequality
being satisfied so here you have the
summation
of the cost of all agents
where the first the agent i chooses
outcomes from the first
let's see from the second excuse me uh
profile and everybody else chooses from
the first
and then uh this is the social cost in
these two states
like as long as this is satisfied then
immediately
this results the following price of
price of energy bound
lambda over one month mu okay
and the proof okay
which uh what afghan understood these
are like that was a way to rewrite the
the proof by the initial proof by
cochitas just
just follows from these three lines okay
so the first line is just the definition
of the social cost
essential cost is just the summation
of the cost of all users the second line
is just a nice equilibrium well
you know
so if s is a nasa equilibrium then if i
deviate my cost can only increase
and then the last line just comes from
the definition of lambda and smoothness
again
and then just rearranging okay remember
uh
s is not equilibrium and s prime could
be the optimum state okay it can be a
for any state
okay so just by arranging you get the
price of final key of lambda over one
minus mu
and particularly the case of linear
congestion games is just a specific
instantiation of this more general
technique for the case where lambda and
you have these two constants
okay five over three one over three all
right
uh yeah let me know if you have any
questions at any point
okay of course
uh we're not done
uh pioneers equipment are even harder to
compute than mixed mass and we have like
a bunch of like uh really hardness
results here by
constitues
and friends
and then there are also other hard
problems communication complexity and
even if these two problems are not hard
enough you know
you can definitely
have even very simple games like zero
sum games agent behavior not converging
okay
so a lot of problems
you cannot expect to to guarantee
equilibration and and pure nasal
liberation
so you know we'll go to our
to our favorite pair of slides okay just
do not regret we know how to do that
and uh yeah so okay
this is uh my cartoon slides okay we
went
uh we went over them in the previous
talk
and we know how to do it and then we
know how to do it uh so here's like the
pro typical algorithm multiplicative
weight updates you know as long as you
use let's say some decreasing sequence
of step sizes particularly one over
square root of t
you get the square root of the aggregate
regret right and as we said like if you
if you're willing to
to
you know consider the case of continuous
times you can actually get constant
regret so all good
so this nordic great properties it's
actually guaranteed for free okay
all right
so what do not regret properties
by us from the perspective of
equilibration again
so we have this notion of nasa
equilibrium
and here what i did is i've actually
reformulated the definition a little bit
i gave i give that in a kind of like
artificial way
so say nas equilibrium is a probability
distribution over outcomes
that is also a product of mixed
strategies okay that it's equal to the
product of its marginals
such that
no agent has a profitable deviating
strategy
okay now i'm going to remove
okay so that's the of course the
the nash equilibrium i'm going to remove
the restriction
that this probability distribution over
the outcomes has to be a product
okay
if i just do that the simple like
somehow removal now you have a different
equilibrium concept altogether so
clearly that's that's a relaxation right
has just to remove the constraint so the
set can only get larger right
and that's what we call by coarse
correlate equilibrium
okay
and just to give you an example okay of
a course called equilibrium
in practice
okay shears has a distribution
here's a distribution that that chooses
uniformly each of these three outcomes
okay so the first rock rock probability
third
paper paper probability third and
scissor scissors
probability third right
and uh now i claim that no player has a
debating strategy why is that the case
well look let's let's do the role player
in expectation i get zero
okay
and now suppose i deviate and let's say
i play rock with probability one
then
what does what's my new expected utility
well my opponent somebody asked about
this question in the previous previous
talk my opponent does not change his
distribution so my opponent's marginal
staying invariant so my opponent would
play one third of the time rock
one third of the time paper one third of
the time caesar's okay but now i'm
playing raw with probability one
but my expected i think this is still
zero
so i cannot deviate and improve my my
utility right and the same for paper and
the same for scissors
okay so this
this is the distribution satisfy the
definition that i give you so it's a
course called equilibrium
okay
and now there's a thing in between
the thing in between is called the
correlate equilibrium okay and now it's
it's a
it's a restriction on the set of nash on
the set of sorry of course equilibria of
course called equilibria
and it's a following restriction
is like now i ask
i require that no agent has a profitable
deviating strategy even if
the player is allowed to deviate after
receiving the advice
from the joint distribution okay
so
just as a is anyone okay can someone see
why this is
is this a correlate equilibrium
no okay correct why because suppose i
received the advice let's say of i'm
asked to play it off by the distribution
well now i can condition on this
information okay so condition this
information that i also play a rock i
know that my opponent plays with
probability one
but if my opponent plays with
probability one then i can do much
better right i can just play paper
okay so this is a case where
i have it i have something that is a
course called equilibrium but it's not a
covalent equilibrium okay
and that's it
that's our universe of uh and just one
last thing if it's not if it's not
obvious that like every coiled
equilibrium
right there's no way to
since the distribution is a product
there's no way somehow to take any
advantage by giving by being given some
information right so this is the
this is the our universe okay kyonos
equilibria which are only guaranteed to
exist in in very special games like
potential games or congestion games
mix equilibria which are guaranteed to
exist in all games
but they're computationally hard and
then covalent equilibria and course
called equilibria which are much easier
to compute both in a centralized and
decentralized way okay
all right that's all good
all right so
no regret
they have a very intimate connection
well effectively they're like one and
the same
like um okay let's look at this this uh
this sentence
a history of knowledge algorithms
is a sequence of outcomes
such that no agent has a single
deviating action that can increase your
average payoff okay this is by the
definition of regret right
so regret means that like no single
player
can play let's say you know can deviate
to some fixed action with hindsight and
do something better okay
and uh uh and then because we're we're
okay with sublinear
uh regret we're talking about average
payout okay
so this is the definition of a of a
sequence of negative outcomes his
definition of a course called
equilibrium
it's just a probability distribution now
it's not a sequence over time just for a
real distribution of your outcomes such
that
the exactly the same thing no agent has
a single deviating action that can
increase your expected payoff okay
so so it's almost like here proved by
pointing words
like on the slide like if you take a
history of no regret outcomes and you
create a distribution that just samples
like one of the first t outcomes
uniformly at random
as it goes to infinity
this distribution is bound to converge
to the set of coastal equilibrium
okay
and hopefully this we should be clear
all right
uh okay and
the very nice property here
is that
the proofs that we saw that uh developed
by roughgarden with a lambda mu
smoothness
they actually immediately extend
from the bottom the
the bottom most equilibrium solution
concept with the pureness equilibria all
the way to the top
the set of course called equilibrium
okay
and uh remember okay so this is the
proof
that we went through the three lines
together so this comes
from the definition of social cost this
comes from the definition of of
pioneer's equilibria this comes from the
smoothness
okay and
here's the proof how the proof goes for
a possible equilibrium
effectively it's you know it's the same
just
using linearity of expectation
the only thing uh yeah
so the only thing here that that is that
in some sense you have to check is that
like
uh that why that this inequality here
exactly captures the fact that
this uh
this
state s is chosen according to the
probability distribution that uh
that is the cost called equilibrium okay
so that's a very definition right so the
very definition says that like okay if s
is chosen to
according to a course called equilibrium
then
if an agent just deviates and say like
no forget about the advice coming from
the distribution i'm just gonna play
this si star
for all time okay
then uh you know you're only gonna
penalize yourself okay
so the cost would only increase
and everything else is just just
immunity of expectation okay so this is
amazing somehow like inside that that
you know if you
write the proof somehow in a very
specific structure
then um this generalization somehow like
follows
immediately
okay
so
all right
all right so this is somehow like where
we are
right so
we have uh and then i've added like one
other layer
one other layer of solution concept was
like all the way at the top
and we say like okay we have
curious equilibria nas co electrical
diagram
and then all of these
equilibrium solution concepts satisfy
this notion of the price of anarchy
is within a lambda over one minus mu
of the uh social cost of the open state
okay
and so
now what we're going to try to
explore
is to show somehow like okay as i said
try to create a kind of
connection between this kind of
classically known statements
and things coming from uh things
inspired at least to some extent by
uh dynamical system interpretation of
learning games okay and we see that like
maybe there there's some somehow like uh
like caveats or weaknesses in the
framework that possibly open up
opportunities for like future work
particularly within the
uh within the semester okay i said
there's a lot okay so there's a lot
happening here on the slide
so there's five different
so here i give
one to five for the five solution
concepts in the in the uh
sorry
so one to five for this so one is the
top layer two is called equilibrium
three correlated forna mixnas
five tunas
okay
and i will make uh five different
statements
of uh
different level of of
maybe uh
surprising that that i will show that
they're formally true
okay
so first of all about
lambda mu approximately
optimal states
for in some sense in some games this
states can be rather
in the sense that like all agents
although these games the states are
approximately optimal
all legends may be strictly worse in
stat states
in terms of experiencing higher costs
strictly high cost that their mean max
cost okay
so min max cost is what i can guarantee
myself
like if i just try to minimize so this
is like like an absolutely minimal
guarantee right so i'm i'm
playing for myself trying to minimize my
cost
everybody somehow is trying to gag up on
me
okay
and i'm saying that like
in approximately in approximately
optimal states it could be the case
that no single agent can actually
guarantee it's been much better they can
all be doing strictly worse
okay
so there are states there are games
where approximately is not hard it's not
let's say very useful as a concept
number two this is actually something
rather surprising he says that like uh
look
there exists no regret algorithms
in smooth games
okay actually
let's say congestion games linear
congested game
such that
the sequence of not good algorithms play
only strictly dominate searches
okay so in basically dominant strategies
i'm using the most
powerful definition so these are these
are few strategies
which are strictly dominated by another
pure strategy
okay so this is something that like okay
immediately you look at this you compare
it with any other
uh yeah so it would be something like
this
all right so my utility here is you know
let's say this is a utility game this is
one and this is
one you know one this is two and this is
three and this is four okay
so this is strictly greater than this
this is strictly greater than this
again so this is strictly dominated
but only but all players
will only play these charges
in the whole history
okay
all right so
no regret can actually lead to rather if
if you prove nothing else
okay if you don't understand let's say
more about the topology of the orbits
like it could be that norway is rather
weak even in smooth games
okay and i will prove this
actually
both in congestion
so this is for different classes of
smoke games both congestion games and
valid utility games for those who are
like known
know these things okay but now okay
okay we say like okay costco equilibria
can be really weird
what about okay let's we can get
correlated we'll be almost free maybe
we're good again well not quite again
so we'll show that it's possible
to
that exist called equilibria which are
actually selected by replicator dynamics
remember this is an algorithm that has
constant regret okay
and these are like in very simple games
in trivial game and this called
equilibria are formally chaotic
so if you try to predict
the sequence of what we played next
it's impossible
okay so this would be on some sort like
students attractor
the call equilibrium support will be on
the strength attractor
on the on the game okay
number four is like okay look
all right course guys could be gonna be
pretty weird quality over here can be
pretty weird
well let's go for nash
okay now
uh
my knowledge here would be like yeah
these are people that's right
like uh then uh
oh actually this is a relatively unknown
but but very strong and counter-duty
result that says
all mixed like nasa equilibria even
partially mixed
in every game
again in every game
are not even locally
asymptotically attracting
for all
ftl dynamics
so take ftl algorithms which have low
regret and
take and put them in continuous time
so now they're supercharged
they have constant regret okay and i'm
saying like okay this is the best we can
do for the grid the the best thing i
have to do is do something like
discretization magic and get the same
performance and discrete time and i'm
saying like okay forget about
digitization tricks
like go for the easy case again
and now give them the simplest possible
problem
okay
find an asset a mixness equilibrium and
i'm saying like forget about ppid
hardness forget about starting in some
weird part of the state space i'm gonna
get arbitrarily close
as close as you want
go to the 2 to the minus 50
ball from that equilibrium
and all i'm asking from the algorithm is
to do the last step
again just
it's there
go
no
not a single game
not a single mix not equilibrium
but a single ftl dynamics
can give you this
who knows no no it could it could be
doing it maybe cycling
maybe it goes away
but one thing that will not happen
is this
is the thing that we want
okay
no never
hey this is what you want right
so for any okay so here's here's the
statement again i mean i will go into
details okay so let's so i have a
specific slide for each of them so let
me go through the i'm not going through
the specifics one time
and last but not least
again
now i'm going all the way down to the
bottom rock bottom okay pure nice
and i will pray i will
prove something that that
my claim is rather counterintuitive okay
that the pure price of anarchy of a fine
congestion games is unbounded
now you say like
what okay it's the price of variety over
the worst pure nuts
okay
all right remember
like uh the result i i claimed
with uh okay we have to revisit we have
to revisit that slide again but we saw a
result you know pakistan subjects and
then the follow-up by
by a rough garden and said like in the
case of linear congestion games
okay pressure firing is five over two
now say if you go from linear to a fine
it's unbounded
okay but so let's go
to one one of this point one at a time
okay
all right so then
okay arguably hey this is something that
uh
it's a it's a
here's a property that
i guess here's the simplest possible
game two balls to bring okay
uh
and then as i said like this is a linear
congestion game it's arguably a very
very simple one so we know what the
price of energy if all of them is it's
2.5
all right
but here's the case like for this game
it's impossible actually to create any
state
let alone an equilibrium state
which factor more than two from alt okay
so here like okay like the 2.5 is is
it's just a trivial statement okay but
you see like okay maybe this is
just okay this is just a small example
but it already shows you something weird
right
that you have some guarantees
and for the game if you really care
about this game
you don't really know anything
given the approximate optimality
grantees okay
but now can this happen over large
classes
the answer is yes
okay so here's
my favorite example
and balls and beans okay
co suits any arbitrarian okay now that's
a clash of games okay
again it's a linear congestion game so
again we know the price of the robust
price of rank is two over five
okay
uh and at optimum this is trivial that's
why the example is chosen the optimum
has like all agents pay a price of one
right
but now
what is the safety
what's the mean max value for the agents
in this case
well the minimum strategy this just by
symmetry
you have like you know
each player the player chooses uniformly
at random strategy like one over n and
then it doesn't matter if everybody else
tries to bang up on you right
so
if you play so i'm i'm the one guy i'm
trying to play defensively unpredictably
one over then
okay
and now let's see
even if all of the other players would
say
use this the first
use the first machine then what's my
cost
well with probability
n minus one over n i'm just by myself
so i just pay a cost of one right
and then
with probability one over n
well now everybody
like you know is on the same bin with me
so i have the maximum cost of n
okay but that's
1
and that is 1 minus 1 over n
so this is 2 minus 1 over n okay
and nothing else nothing else can happen
to you
so just by min max
i know that i should not be paying more
than two
so the social
the mean max
price of arc is less than two okay
but
this
is still less
than the robust value
so for these games
like even if it doesn't matter how fast
it get goes to zero
we don't know anything more and what we
knew
you know using like the
black wheels like min max results again
so program of the multi in some class of
games could be rather weak and there we
need something more
okay maybe we need like uh yeah we need
something more
okay and here here's something
interesting uh
inaudible games
okay in smooth games
it can be the case
that all agents play strictly dominate
strategies again
how's that possible
how's it possible it feels like
counter-intuitive right
so here's a here's a simple example
uh
so
we have like two agents
and four available paths
so the paths
you have
all the agents need go from point a to
point b
yes
yes
hey sorry to chime in
any chance you're willing to go back to
your previous example yes
like the price of energy on this
particular
uh
example of
of a game is not actually 2.5 or i don't
think it is right it's a concrete game
the worst case is that but this is not
the worst case right yeah that's that's
a great point eva here's what i'm saying
right
suppose okay of course the price of
finality for this game is going to be
much smaller than the 0.5
but for me but suppose all you know
is you have the n players
and they use regret minimizing
algorithms
so like the first one uses
ftrl with euclidean regularizer the
second is like ftl
the third one is we get matching the
fourth one is whatever you want okay
so now
nobody has analyzed this combination of
neuralgia algorithms so we don't know
that they converge to nash
so all that we know
is that the regret goes to zero
okay
and i'm saying like if that's all we
know
then for this specific game
there's nothing
the the only price of five gives up that
i know they're gonna apply is 2.5
but do you know an example on a concrete
game where there is a
high
cost
course correlated equilibrium and
yet the minimax value is is lower
sorry can you repeat that ever
i mean i'm just wondering if there
really is an example on a concrete game
where which has a high cost course
correlated equilibrium and that
you know with a low cost
min max min max cost
yeah i mean this would be such an
example right no it's not because i
don't where is the course created
equilibrium that's costing so high i i
don't i okay so here one you have like
the mixedness okay so the problem
right uh
right i mean maybe okay uh because let's
return like let's have this question
session maybe at the end
okay fine sorry no but thank you thank
you you know
i'll be very yeah i'll be very much
willing to have this discussion
but actually i don't think it's the most
interesting result so that's why i want
to proceed again
all right so here's the statement now
i'm going to say that like it could be
the case that you have like a bunch of
negative algorithms and your regret
could be actually constant
and you can have a smooth game
and this algorithm this type of nerf
guide algorithms could actually be
playing only stable dominant strategies
right
so here's an example but that's a linear
congestion game
okay
just two agents
they want to go from point a to point d
again
and they have like four available parts
so this
this
this and this
okay so clearly
i have added some like superfluous paths
so this is strictly dominated by this
and this is strictly dominated by this
again
right
so now i claim
let's take this distribution
with 50 probability
uh the first agent uses this path
here and the other so both players use
the strictly dominate paths but they
alternate
with physical superability you have this
pair with some ability of the other pair
okay
so i'm going to claim that like this is
actually called the co-squad equilibrium
let's see this so what's the cost for
any player so everything's symmetric
so the cost for any player here is uh so
it's zero point one and one
okay so it's one point one
all right
and similarly for the other player okay
now let's see what will happen if they
deviate
so clearly the only thing i can deviate
is symmetric is to use let's say this
path abd abd
okay here
they pay a cost of one
okay but here let's say uh let's choose
the deviating agent
so the deviation let's say it's the red
agent okay so the deviation will play
abd both graphs
in the first graph he pays cost of one
in the second graph however he pays cost
of two
so in average its 3.2 is 1.5
so that's strictly higher than 1.1
so actually this
is a it's a state that has negative
regret for all agents
okay
all right and this is just a smooth game
okay
now the thing is like okay you can say
like okay this is like a really weird
weird weird example
like i'm sure
nor gatling algorithms would never find
this
but unfortunately
due to some
work done with eva actually
uh and some follow-up work with my
student barnaby
you can actually construct not regret
algorithms
that for any arbitrary game
they can reproduce
as the unique somehow
time average
any cost correlated equilibrium of our
choice
no matter how
irrational they are
okay
putting these both results together
again
there exists
not a good algorithms such that in
smooth games
only strictly dominate strides are
played by all agents
okay
and here's the
intuitively the idea behind this
this uh no regret algorithms
so it's not going to do the following
it's like okay
well so let's say me and constitution
like we're gonna agree to try to
simulate this weird equilibrium with the
two agents okay so i play this you play
that
all all
games all days we do this
even days we do that okay the first time
somebody deviates we just say like oh
forget forget our agreement just play
multiplicative updates with decreasing
step sizes
and that's it
this result in this specific case will
never deviate
and will converge to the course called
equilibrium of our choice
even if it's very unnatural
in any other game
like immediately you you know it doesn't
matter if immediately or not like you
cannot accrue regret okay
so your your total regret remains
bounded
and you convert to this very unnatural
behavior okay now admittedly
these are like super super weird
dynamics
like no dynamic of any
human being that's not a theoretical
computer scientist that has to create
artificial counter examples would have
this kind of behavior okay
but it's important to know
because this says something about
theoretical papers
but if your theoretical paper does
analysis of algorithms using regret
alone
then you cannot
guarantee
that you cannot have this behavior you
need to prove something more
again
and this is not just for congestion
games but also effectively the same
example applies for the other uh you
know
let's say for valid utility games and
quite possibly for other smooth games as
well so i haven't tried to be exhausted
here okay but both of
these two well-known classic games they
can they have this weakness
yes do you believe that the ftra type
regret
can
converse really
great thank you thank you
thank you guys
another yes it's not but like i will go
to this right now okay okay cool all
right i didn't i did you didn't pay me
i doubly upgraded
okay uh okay
right so yeah great uh so danny says
okay what about really good very natural
not to get algorithms well you know
what's my candidate of choice replicator
okay so replicators for me is the salon
is that the thing i'm trying to
replicate in discrete time
and just get it very quickly in
continuous time okay
so here's the thing
with replicator
you can effectively
even in normal in normal from games okay
orbits of replica dynamics in normal
from games even with just two agents can
be arbitrarily complex
and what i'm saying here is that
by arbitrarily complex here we have like
a target
dynamical system this is a
a well-known formal etiotic system was
not the the chua system okay
we have a mechanistic process an
algorithm
that tells you okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna try to simulate this
process using replicator
okay give me a game and an initial
condition
so that these two orbits are similarly
formally similarly close
okay
and you can do this
so you can formally create actually
simple two-player games simple large you
need a high dimensionality okay
who's whose orbits are this so this is
actually a replicator orbit okay so you
can actually compute the regret of this
the bit of this could be like total you
get would be something like five
okay
it doesn't look at it
doesn't look like it
but this is a perfect cc
again
okay and i can say like okay
ccs can be very very bad
what about correlated equilibria maybe
that's our way out you know we know how
to do reductions okay almost for free
from cc to ce to coil at equilibria okay
is it the case that
coil equilibrium are good
the answer is no again
you can create
okay instead of using let's say two
players and a lot of strategies to get
flexibility from the strategies
just use several agents but only two
strategies for each
and if the players have only two
strategies then costco equilibrium
correlate could be a coincide
again
this
is an attractor
in a six player two strategy game which
is actually formally chaotic
okay this is like a strange attractor so
this actually leverages some result in
dynamical system theory but this is
actually formal cure
okay
uh yeah so
colette coliglia which are like
naturally selected
can be formally chaotic
okay
even in games with
six agents two strategies no more phone
games
right so yes
this is an example this is just an
example
the input for the procedure is
effectively the vector field of node
okay
and then
the output of the procedure is a payoff
matrix
and an initial condition
such that
the
the all bits of the dynamical systems
uh
are approximately
simple
so i would say like okay this
approximation error okay
but for some specific versions of the
proofs there's no approximation here
and you can leverage the special cases
to improve formal code
so what so i'll give you what kind of
audi i can give you as input like i give
you i'll literally write down for you an
idea of my choice
so we need okay so so
we have some restrictions so that the
paper is probably some called
so they will have some restrictions on
the allowable so you need the state
space to be homeomorphic
to some simplex
but other than this constraint you're
good
it's a natural
algorithm that doesn't
[Music]
like i mean help so that's a great
question
now you can say that okay look maybe
your applicator is really really weird
okay
maybe
and maybe somehow can you repeat the
question yeah okay sorry so the question
is like okay is this
is there some nordic algorithm that
doesn't have this this particulars
again and i'm saying like yeah i i don't
know
i mean i think it's already i was
surprised that you can actually do this
at all with any algorithm right
and i don't know even know how to prove
a negation of this result
there is some kind of you know
something i mean
yes
yes
it might also be about the game right so
it is very much available yeah if if you
have something like a potential game i
do not expect this behavior oh yeah of
course of course
yeah yes so it's not only about the
dynamics
today you know i can give you the
numbers
of a
six player to start the game like i said
don't simulate this
and you'll see
this
right right
i can't see the code
so okay so the red stuff i wrote exactly
all right so
it's a lower dimensional attractor so
this is a little bit hidden so it is so
there's the infinite number of initial
conditions that converge to this point
but not an opening set
okay
so yeah so these things are not okay
that's something that's important to
point out
so these dynamics
dynamical system behavior is can
actually be hidden
and all of them by construction are
hidden in a lower dimensional zero
measure set of the dynamics so conveyor
will be the case but if i'm not there to
give you the heat i said uh with the
chaos is there
that you never find it
again
so by then because again this is in some
sense this is a hardness result right
it's a construction i i feed i hide like
a very complex dynamic between something
something that could be somehow like not
not complex at a high level
okay
all right so
so closer to the record we'll make a
restart
understand okay what about moving
further down okay what about mixed nuts
okay mixed mass
cannot be strange okay
like mixedness is just the point for
topology it doesn't get any simpler than
this okay but now here's the question
again here's like something that
i was thinking about okay
supposed to say you know at the end of
the semester we're going to write a book
on learning in games we did it you know
we
we did all the cool stuff uh and of
course
it would be nice for the cover
of the of the book
to have some dynamic let's say they
follow their little dynamics
such that they they converged nash okay
here's enough all the things converged
there like maybe spiraling maybe direct
convergence that would be a really cool
picture
well here's one idea
like just use a stick now
well stick nice is kind of like cheating
you know
in some sense like okay if you get super
close to a stick nas
then in some sense a dominate it's a
dominant strategy in that neighborhood
of course everything will convert to
that point
well what about something that's not the
stigma
what something is partially mixed
it's impossible
this comes like from purely from
dynamical systems theory okay in some
sense
to be able to do this
you need to have some something of
positive
measure
that shrinks
again
so you have some some ball of initial
condition that contracts contracts
contracts and and advances into the
equilibrium point
and these dynamics actually do not allow
for this
actually we'll see this tomorrow why
technically this is true again uh but
due to this result okay i mean i find
this to be somehow a stunningly
like stunning somehow like critique from
online from after dynamics for mixedness
economists would say like okay mixed
nuts are
are everything our solution again are
these are the perfect solution
and ftl you put it there
within computer accuracy and you say
like okay
do it
and they won't
never
again
i think i mean i don't know what this
tells me
maybe okay maybe now you said like okay
maybe we've been thinking about dynamics
wrong really wrong
again maybe we really need
optimism for some for example so
optimism can actually solve this but
optimism
the way you can actually prove the
following so optimism is volume
shrinking is near some games but it pays
a price in coordination games
so coordination games becomes volume
expanding
and it becomes chaotic
actually
so the interesting here question here is
like okay can you find the dynamic that
actually works
okay
uh yeah
yes that's for a discussion
that you get there is a
noise
even optimism does not
work well
tricks that we apply
sorry but i'm going to take over
right
yeah okay last five minutes okay i said
the best for last again
i claim the pure passion of our key of
our final distinct games is unbounded
it's infinite again
all right
proof
by example
oh somehow okay there we go proof by
example
okay so here is my game
again two by two so first of all like
okay this is not a contestant game it's
a single game it's a course being
again so high is bad
so this game has clearly two q nas
equilibria
the eight b and the b a b and b a okay
so of course the the price of anarchy
the pure price of iron is exactly w
right so this is the optimum state
with this still in equilibrium this
ratio is w
and w of course can be anything it's a
some positive number
so the supreme over this farming of
games of question is infinite okay
but now i'm already saying like okay you
should start already starting to worry
here's the issue
it's like this is clearly a potential
game
right
it's a potential again it's a potential
game
because all players have the same payoff
so the potential is just a common payoff
right
and by this isomorphism between
potential games condition games
there should be a congestion game with
isomorphics
so let's construct this
okay so here's
here uh so there's two agents
they're always in the corner
and there are four contested elements
uh
a a
a b
b a b b okay and the row agent has these
two so there are four elements one two
three four
the a strategy for the whale
contains these two sets these two the b
these two
and then for the column region is this
two and these two
and here's the costs
with load of one
the cost of all of this congested
elements is zero
with load of two
the cost is exactly what is the cost of
that cell
again
nothing like that said
this is
the congestion game again
so
the available strategies you know it's a
it's uh so again the available status is
like if i choose a
and on the current player i have to use
this tool if i choose b i have to use
these two for the contrary that way
and i claim that like uh okay
so this is clearly
uh so the the costs are slightly
increasing
okay as you increase the load
everything was considered something
positive okay number one number two is
like they're three very linear
because they're only two points
so this is like a linear
so it's it's not fine so you have to say
it's in a fine congestion game
and the pressure front is infinity
all right how
fast is possible
that's how we're doing
what's going on here
sorry what's the question
okay so i i have a claim here and i said
the purpose of rp or final decent gains
is infinity okay and i'm saying like how
how can we ameliorate this
with the
results by future chris crystal and
gutierrez
and rough guardian of the five over two
how how can this both be right
yes
[Music]
no approximation whatsoever
this is a perfectly
valid
a fine
congestion game
just to be clear i mean these functions
take two possible arguments
yes
uh
all start at zero and go somewhere where
are they gonna be here yeah they are
uh what do you mean by a fine i mean
like w is not the input to any of these
functions right like
they go from you know
like at one they they're zero at one yes
so they're like kind of like with zero
they're kind of like uh rarity functions
but they don't have to be okay just put
everything up actually raise everything
by an action okay let's not make let's
not talk about luke here it's like
normal for you please i don't want to go
crazy you
all right
so here is empty loan
here's something like sticking larger
than actually okay
two points increasing
again it's a fine
what what's
how can this bother be right
correct the intercept is negative let's
let's revisit this assumption again
right so this assumption here
alpha x plus beta
again about the cost function
and of course alpha
increasing is very natural what i want
to claim is like i don't i don't feel
that better
being positive
not negative
is
such a universal assumption so let me
try to go over this again
so here's the thing first of all how do
you even test
two minutes
how do you even test that beta is zero
and beta is not negative
cost at zero
is not defined
this is not something you can measure
on any machine okay the cost is only
defined for load one two three four five
and so forth again
so even if somebody were to
give you oracle access
this
better greater than or equal to zero is
equivalent to two times the cost of
labor one
is greater than equal than costa two
okay and my question to you is why two
why not
three 100
and i'm saying it's like and actually
you can imagine okay like let me give
you an example like i think you can
create three simple examples that have
this property but here's a trivial one
again think of a printer again a printer
that that before that somehow when it
prints the last page
it preloads
like paper and whatever the printer
needs to do for the first
for the first
uh
page again as a result the cost of
printing the first page would be smaller
because it has already done the
prebooting
okay
so that's like anything that's so like
you know any server that's like preload
resources could very well
disqualify this assumption and and to be
honest i don't see any special reason
why two
like two feels like an arbitrary
constant
but it's necessary
it's necessary for five over two
if you remove this assumption you say
like okay all i'm asking
is the function to be increasing
and everywhere positive
two pairs of five is infinite
okay that's it
and of course this immediately
propagates to any polynomial function
take any polynomial function again i'm
saying like okay you use
right so
cos functions you know in practice
they're not written down by hand you
take multiple noisy measurements and you
do some like some linear or polynomial
regression to do something like maximum
likelihood estimator and so so forth to
try to infer them okay
you know i'm saying like okay what
happens if some of these constants the
non-leading ones we have high
uncertainty are negative
why is this why is this impossible
okay
well if they are negative then we know
nothing
actually nothing holds nothing persists
like pressure frankie is infinite
that's it
so
i'm done i'm done again
but what i'm pointing out here is like
look
like i think we don't need to run and
say like look i really think that in
this semester we should not be thinking
just about ai
and reinforcement learning like i think
there are some very valid very
interesting questions in normal phone
games
and i think as we work together
putting all of our skills like there's a
lot of mathematical technology
in the area of like lambda mu robustness
and smoothness are really really
powerful ideas okay
and i think
the combinations of this and dynamical
systems will only give us like more
power okay
and to be honest i'm kind of excited
about these things they give us a new
challenge to work on again
so
all right
that's it from me thank you for your
attention
we have time for one question
there's a question from the audience
okay we'll have that tomorrow as well
thank you thank you thank you
you